before you franchise a concept you
really you're franchising a brand you're
franchising an operating system and
obviously the the product uh in the
method of that that the product is
prepared so you have to have that
screwed down pretty tight I tell people
this if people are able to execute your
concept at 80 efficiency okay not the
hundred percent that you believe you do
or or that everyone should but only
eighty percent because keep in mind most
people that buy a franchise particularly
a food franchise have little to no
aptitude at all for the industry they
they just don't but that's why they're
buying a franchise they think uh that
it's a sure win and it's it's it's not a
sure win but it's a better odds win